what do all of these Arab Americans have
in common the US government says they're
white say what
as an arab-american myself I wanted to
look into why Arabs are considered white
why the census classification matters
and why changing it may be problematic
there are between two to four million
Arabs in the u.s. who hail from 22
different countries but according to the
Box they're meant to check on the US
Census and other applications they're
white now let's first set aside the fact
that the last time hamid abdullah went
through TSA security he didn't
necessarily reap any of that sweet white
privilege there's actually a history
behind this categorization it dates back
to the 1880s and 1890s when Arabs first
began immigrating to the US from
present-day Lebanon and Syria they
settled in Boston Detroit in New York
establishing restaurants businesses and
newspapers but unlike Irish Italian and
Portuguese immigrants these newcomers
didn't come from Europe they came from
Asia at a time when white Americans felt
that Asians would take their jobs the
Chinese Exclusion Act barred Asian
immigrants from becoming citizens in
fact up until 1952 generally only white
people were eligible to become American
citizens and so Arabs went to court and
fought several cases arguing they should
be classified as white and they won now
back then being white came with a lot of
perks kind of like today and so Arabs
who sought white identification did so
to avoid discrimination in public life
and to be treated better than non-white
minorities but fast forward to today's
post 9/11 America Arabs are
discriminated against regularly at
airports and courts by the government
and by the police many feel they're not
treated as full American citizens let
alone white so you might be asking why
does the Box on the census even matter
well for one having better data on the
US population gives us a more complete
picture of how diverse the country is
becoming and policymakers can
potentially better serve the needs of
their constituencies if they know more
about them the Arab American population
has basically been invisible and hasn't
gotten the benefits of having federal
minority status that's why during the
2010 census activists encourage folks to
check it right you ain't white they
argue that having actual data on the
size of the community is helpful for
political mobilization tracking hate
crimes applying for federal grants for
minority-owned businesses being
considered for affirmative action and
health research in 2013 Arab American
and academics sent the US Census Bureau
a letter to include a Middle Eastern or
North African category for the next
census in 2020 and the government is
considering that today but it's a
double-edged sword and not every Arab
American is on board some warned that
handing the government specific numbers
and data will only result in more
surveillance and profiling and there's
reason to be cautious data from the
Census Bureau was used to round up
japanese-americans and internment camps
during World War two and in the years
after 9/11 the Census Bureau shared
survey information with the Department
of Homeland Security on the Arab
community including details on Arabs and
specific zip codes and that raised a lot
of eyebrows among civil rights groups so
in the future Arabs may no longer have
to check white but will the positives of
this development outweigh the potential
dangers